-It is the holiday season.
So, in spirit of giving,
I got each team a gift.
And by gift,
I mean a mystery box
full of unknown
and possibly dangerous things.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how this game works.
Each box has some random objects
inside
that represent a well-known song
or artist.
On your turn, you and your
partner will both reach inside
and try to figure out
the answer
using only your sense of touch.
You have 45 seconds
to feel it out.
Each box is worth 1,000 points.
And there may or may not be
live animals in some of these.
Fred and Ana,
you're up first.
Let's reveal what's in
your mystery box.
-Do we both feel stuff
at the same time?
-We're both at the same time,
right?
-Yes, you both feel.
Don't look.
I'm revealing.
♪♪
-Remember, it could be a person.
-Aah-aah-aah!
-It could be
a musical performer.
-It could be!
[ Laughter ]
Let's get 45 seconds
on the clock.
Shout out when you think
you know
what the song or artist it is.
3, 2, 1...feel.
-Here we go.
♪♪
-Well, Freddy went right in.
Ooh, my God!
Oh, my gosh! Fred!
-Chain, chain.
Uh...
-Oh, my gosh!
-Beads?
-Alice in Chains?
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
-Who --
-I have, like...
Goo balls. The Goo Balls?
-Wait, wait, wait.
I've got a can --
I've got a jar of something.
-They're going right in there.
-Jars of Clay?
-Yeah, I've got a necklace,
pearl necklace.
-Pearl Jam?
-Oh!
-♪ Freezin' ♪
♪ Rest his head on a pillow
made of concrete ♪
-Look at that.
That's the album cover.
Look at that. That is it.
Pearl Jam.
Correct! Clean yourself up
back there, guys.
Ana, you went right in there,
by the way.
You had full-on.
You're like...
-I was like --
-"I'm going for it."
-I did not come to play!
-Exactly right!
Wow.
Melissa, Rachel,
you are up next.
Let's see what Santa
brought you.
-Santa?
-He has brought you...
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-[ Humming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Are we going?
-No, wait. Hold on.
-Oh!
-I'm building the suspense.
-Okay.
-Alright, we have 45 seconds
on the clock.
-Hurry up!
-No, don't do that.
-No, we would never do that
to you.
Alright, start feeling --
3, 2, 1.
It's a song or an artist!
It's a song or an artist.
-You're scaring me!
-It's a song...or an artist.
[ Crowd shouting,
clock ticking ]
-It's...it's clay.
It's clay, or it's food.
It's...
It's in a circle, though.
It's in, like, a...
Wait. Do you feel?
What do you feel?
Oh, sand. There's sand.
-It's like a cake.
-There's sand.
"Cake by the Ocean"!
-Oh, my gosh!
Are you kidding me?!
That is correct.
-I didn't know.
-Oh, my gosh!
-♪ I keep hopin'
we'll eat cake by the ocean ♪
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah!
-Does it taste good?
-Yeah, it tastes great.
-I thought this
was like a sponge.
-Yeah, look at that.
-Oh, that looks delicious!
Why are we wasting it?
-You're the best.
Come on.
Somebody's got to eat it, right?
You can clean up right there
if you'd like to.
This towel is there
to clean up.
-I want to eat the cake, though.
-Oh, that's so good.
-That cake looks amazing.
-Alright, we're going
to switch these up for round 2.
We have two boxes
with the same objects inside.
It is a race to see which team
can feel out the answers first.
Let's see what's inside first.
[ Humming ]
♪♪
[ Humming continues ]
Now, this time, buzz in
with your other hand
when you think that you have
the right answer.
But if you're wrong,
then the other team can steal.
Reach inside --
3, 2, 1...
go.
-Aah! Aah!
-Stuffed animal.
-It's a doll.
It's a baby doll.
-Dolls.
Goo Goo Dolls? Goo Goo Dolls?
-I don't know.
-It's like fur. It's fur.
-It's alive!
-It's not alive.
-Yeah, it is!
Something's alive in there!
-It's a Christmas song.
-It's moving.
Oh, is that your hand?
-That's just my hand.
-Oh! [ Laughs ]
-You're feeling Rachel's hand.
It's the youngest resident
of the North Pole.
-Youngest resident?
-Santa...baby...
"Santa Baby"!
-Yeah! Oh, my gosh!
Rachel Dratch, you did it.
-♪ Santa baby ♪
-"Santa Baby."
[ British accent ]
It's baby Santa.
-"Santa Baby."
-It's baby.
A baby.
-[ British accent ]
Ah, a little baby.
-A little baby.
-For the love of Pete!
Baby with a beard.
Look -- he wants to get out.
No, get back in that box.
You did good, baby.
-That baby has a lot of hair.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah,
it's a very hairy baby.
Let's move up here, guys,
while they clear out the boxes.
-Um, Jimmy?
-Yes.
-Fred and I would like
to apologize to the charity
that we were playing for.
We're playing
against the human jukebox,
Rachel Dratch.
-Yeah, you are really
crushing it tonight.
-Yeah, no, I should go home.
-You said -- you said cake.
She said cake.
-Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, let's do
one final round.
Big feels on this one because
it's worth 5,000 points!
-What?!
-The comeback.
The comeback -- everyone's
watching to see the comeback.
Get into positions.
Now, here's the deal.
All four of you will be reaching
into one box at the same time.
You're gonna need to wear gloves
for this one.
-Oh, gross.
-We just use one hand, right?
-Now let's see
what you'll be feeling, okay?
-Okay.
-Don't freak out. It's all good.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
-Why are you acting
like it's alive?
-They don't like this.
-Remember when -- when you think
you know what it is,
buzz in, okay?
Ooh!
-You're scaring me.
-No, why would I scare you?!
I would never scare you!
-Is it a snake?
-On the holiday jam --
-It's a holiday jam?
-No, it's not.
Alright, reach inside...now.
♪♪
-Is that -- that's your hand.
-Feels like a box.
-It's a hot...
-It's like a box of something.
[ Clock ticking ]
-Oh, there's something warm.
-What?!
-It's a scuba diver.
-It's something warm.
It's a person.
-It's a person.
-Oh, there's something warm.
Oh, God!
-It's a person.
-It's like a head.
It's somebody's head in here!
-It's a '90's group.
♪ What are you waiting for? ♪
[ Clock ticking ]
-So...
-Head is sticky.
Feels like...
♪♪
-Yes, Ana?
-Radiohead!
-That is correct!
-Yay!
-Great-sounding voice!
-Oh, my gosh.
There was a radio
on his head.
-Oh!
♪ Just like an angel ♪
And you caught up
just like that.
Come on!